geese would have already attacked me in
here
[Music]
i'm will compton bustle with the boys
here to answer the internet
would you rather give up sex or the tv
remote for the rest of your life tv
remote
it's a no-brainer
no brainer
it's a no [ __ ] brainer boys no no
you're not giving the justice deserves
it's not a no-brainer it's a no-brainer
so tell me you're giving up sex for the
rest of your life anybody in here
you're basically giving up tv for the
rest of your life too though no this is
the remote without the remote how the
[ __ ] are you gonna what are you gonna do
yeah that's true it's not like i watch a
lot and you know my girl we watch the
same kind of shows like she'll handle
the remote i might have to watch a batch
of red in extra couple nights but
at the end of the day i'm enjoying it
enjoying sex
who would win any street fight michael
vick or tim tebow i almost went with the
low-hanging fruit joke right here about
old vic it's hard to beat the son of
christ
i'm gonna go tim tebow
if you could eliminate one state sport
team uh pro in college what state would
it be get rid of philly
that's what i'm saying i think they're
necessary
i would say hey texas
they're annoying they all think they're
the best all the time they have a
shitload of teams like just get rid of
the state
they're like poor honestly
you wish me good
like just get rid of the state dude if
you could only have
four teeth in your entire mouth where
would they be
the front i've had [ __ ] teeth and i
would have all four of them right here
up front
i'm gonna have to drink my food i'm
gonna have to live lift through a straw
if bart still had a beauty pageant
what would your talent be i don't have a
whole lot dude i think i would lose i'd
be in the beauty pageant i mean i think
i would fail
you're pretty mad
just smile we're gonna say world peace
i wouldn't be very good you could play
football
a full-grown great white versus a
full-grown polar bear in an
olympic-sized swimming pool that is
seven feet deep and 75 degrees
fahrenheit who wins i think you got to
go polar bear for the reason that i
think it can it can maneuver a little
bit more it's a little more limber has
some more brains the polar bear can use
his paws
the polar bear can use i think it'll be
able to grip a hold of him you know what
i mean put him maybe in the front
headlock yeah if a human being can
escape a great white obviously not win
to the death i think a polar bear can
take a great white usually it's a
a grizzly bear versus a gorilla i think
you got to go with a uh a grizzly bear
watching him stand on on their hind legs
and swipe like those fights are insane
would you go to a football game at a 70
000 seat stadium if you knew that 500
seats would get ejected into a black
hole but everyone who didn't get ejected
would get five million dollars i would
i would
risk versus reward you get five million
dollars
if you get ejected
i mean that was that was just in the
plans man that's what god
and also the conte like content you go
down you die young you die hero
what would the number have to be if it
was like
a thousand seas ten thousand seats if it
was half the seats where would you stop
because those are pretty good numbers
500 out of 70 000 but yeah that's like
that's that's you know like
if half the stadium just goes and you're
like
what's 10 percent of 70 000. what is
that 7 000 yeah so 700 is one percent
uh
seven
just 700 is your answer
i'm saying 700 one percent i'm working
on i'm working on percentages here
i would say i would go up to um a 10
chance okay so seven thousand
seven thousand seats yeah yeah we got a
voice
[Laughter]
who's hotter ariel or jasmine
jasmine
no and then no disrespect no disrespect
would you rather a girlfriend be able to
read your thoughts during sex
or all the time except during sex during
sex i think it's a no-brainer i think
that's an easy like you you don't want
them to know your thoughts at all times
of the day there's real bad things out
yeah there's real bad things on public
you know what i mean
who's the best fat athlete of all time
would it be the fridge who are you
thinking of warren sapp is a good one
yeah but he's like what are we
considering fat here are we talking like
okay is butter bean in the equation
you know what i mean like butter beans
you got haynesworth but he was lazy yeah
haynesworth well hansworth was like
until he got fat and then he got back
yeah
i i tell you what though
warren sapp would be tough to beat i
think warren sapp and all the he's a
little combine like he always did the
pro bowl stuff all the little agile
drills like warren sapp is a monster
which fictional character would you love
to beat the [ __ ] out of
mine is the the kid from game of thrones
joffrey i would love to beat the [ __ ]
out of joffrey dude
i [ __ ] hate that kid i probably
wouldn't like him in real life like just
hey you did so well that's a compliment
like that's a compliment but i hate the
person in real life if you had to win a
game show to stay alive which game show
would you choose i wouldn't be able to
win who wants to be a millionaire i
think i'd have to take my chances with
deal or no deal actually
what are some of the ones where you get
to kind of play like catch phrase
they've been out recently i just can't
figure i can't remember their name
like the heads up catchphrase like
they're kind of like
yeah
i think i could win those
50 000 pyramid i think we would you need
to make a call you need to have kelly
making calls
would you rather a have a flock of geese
swarm or swarm to you every time you
fart or b never use a phone or computer
again geese would have already attacked
me in here
so
i think i would
i think i would go uh i think i'd have
to do flock of geese because how can you
live without a phone or a computer it's
20 21. i'm just thinking about so how
many times a day
i would get attacked quite a bit i'm
gonna get it that quiet quite a bit dude
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon